[Aplausos]
bueno el desarrollo social es una ruta
de crisis respuestas y preguntas que nos
hacemos las preguntas adecuadas esas
crisis nos permiten avanzar una de las
crisis que tuvimos que enfrentar hace
unos años en colombia fue después de
unas fuertes lluvias en invocó al
municipio que llevaron a las
inundaciones ya que una población entera
se quedará paradójicamente por las
lluvias que hubo se quedará sin agua nos
vimos abocados muchos como a pensar
haciendo una pregunta de cómo vamos a
lograr que tuvieran agua a las
comunidades indígenas los niños agua
potable en medio de esas circunstancias
muchos nos pusimos en manos a la obra y
entonces se construyeron tuberías
por todo el lomo cosas se llevaron se
llevó agua se pusieron carro tanques y
bueno en este proceso llegamos a una
comunidad una comunidad indígena ya
estaba el taita y bueno dijimos bueno
está contento aquí that le llevó el tubo
el depósito son los filtros y todo y me
dijo mire yo quisiera que usted más bien
su era de hecho esta pregunta ahora que
yo abrí la llave no me salió agua en
cambio vivimos la paradoja todos los
años porque esto no es nuevo de que cada
vez que llueve no tenemos agua
entonces después de haber hecho todo
este enorme esfuerzo de llevar los tubos
mirando el entorno y entendiendo cuál
era el planteamiento que nos estaba
haciendo me di cuenta que la de lluvia
ya llegaba sola el agua ya llegaba sola
y que quizás lo que hubiéramos tenido
que hacer era inventarnos unos tanques
de agua y unos sistemas de filtrado que
permitieran aprovechar el potencial
hídrico que les generaba la crisis pero
que también podía tener la solución
eso nos pasa muchas veces en el trabajo
social
y la respuesta que damos no
necesariamente es la más adecuada porque
no nos hacemos la pregunta que es y es
cómo hacer cambios en las necesidades
que tiene la gente en este caso la
necesidad de tener agua como lo
acercamos a la oferta a la oferta ya
estaba ahí estaba el agua y quizás la
respuesta estaba más vinculada la
potabilización en estos momentos de
pandemia que estamos en una crisis en
este confinamiento pues yo veo como todo
el mundo se está haciendo estas
preguntas y no solamente unos y las
preguntas es cómo hacemos para que los
niños puedan tener educación si no
pueden ir a la escuela cómo hacemos para
que la gente pueda tener acceso a la
salud si no puede salir al centro médico
esas preguntas que nos hacemos
constantemente también nos llevan a una
reflexión y es porque para poder tener
educación tenemos que ir
o porque para poder tener acceso a la
salud tenemos que ir hasta el centro de
salud como hacemos para acercar la
oferta y la demanda y no tengo la
respuesta de ambos solamente tengo la
pregunta y la pregunta es qué es lo que
tenemos que mover a qué y en qué
circunstancias y voy a dar algunos
ejemplos el ejemplo del agua es un
ejemplo es un ejemplo muy interesante lo
que vemos es que la haría una respuesta
social que ha sido actuar llevar tubos
transportar el agua por todas partes
pero en muchos casos el agua está ahí y
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer sobre
todo es poderla potabilizar también voy
a llegar a la paradoja de tener
kilómetros y kilómetros de tubería y no
tener agua potable y entonces volver a
la pregunta cuál era mi objetivo tener
agua potable obtener kilómetros de
tubería entonces estas son por ejemplo
las paradojas entre las preguntas y las
respuestas de cómo acercar la demanda y
la oferta por supuesto ahorita estamos
viviendo una tensión donde tenemos que
tratar de resolver todo esto a gran
velocidad
y entonces estamos viendo por ejemplo
cómo hacemos para que los niños puedan
tener computadores en sus casas y a
través del internet acercar la educación
a los niños y vamos a demandante de la
educación que son los niños y parece que
la única ruta pues ese es el internet o
las vidas virtuales sin embargo ese
problema no es nuevo
gauss la pregunta de cómo cómo hacemos
que la gente pueda acceder a la
educación es una pregunta que
socialmente nos hemos hecho y una de las
respuestas que nos hemos dado es hacer
infraestructura para que los niños
tengan que ir pues hasta las
experiencias con la respuesta tampoco
espacio y no crean que se las voy a
hacer tan fácil hace unos años pudiera
asistir a uno de los de los barrios
digamos más marginales
en bogotá y vimos cómo los niños decía
que uno de los principales problemas era
que no podían ir a la escuela entonces
la solución que todos pensamos desde las
ciencias sociales fue de construir una
escuela lo más cercana posible como es
una zona marginal pues construyeron una
escuela donde no había agua no había luz
y pues tampoco podían llegar los
maestros conclusión aunque la escuela
estaba más cerca de la escuela que no
era posible acceder a ella es decir se
acercó la oferta pero no necesariamente
ésta mejoró la accesibilidad
bueno después de ver poco las puertas
cerradas de la escuela le preguntábamos
a los niños y ustedes por qué no pueden
ir a la escuela entonces dije bueno
nosotros no podemos ir a la escuela
básicamente porque la ruta tenemos que
bajar muy peligrosa y atraviesa un río
un río muy pequeño que no podemos
atravesar entonces pues si hubiera un
puentecito y hubieron bus la verdad es
que allí a 10 minutos que a una escuela
fantástica y podríamos ir a la escuela
en este caso a acercar la demanda la
oferta hubiera sido haber puesto un bus
lo que quiero decir con esto es que una
de las preguntas si esa en la que
estamos enfrentados completo es cómo
hacemos ese proceso hasta también el
placer la demanda y la respuesta pues no
es única la respuesta son múltiples
respuestas y tiene que ver con un
análisis del territorio un análisis del
territorio que se refiere no solamente
un análisis físico del territorio sino
un análisis también de cuál es la
estructura de esa comunidad cómo se
interrelaciona qué tan dispersa está qué
tan cercana a cuáles son las condiciones
ambientales dónde está el agua donde
está el sol donde están las fuentes que
producen las posibilidades de resolver
las principales necesidades que tiene
una población y por último pues también
todos los potenciales que tiene ese
territorio y cuando me refiero al
territorio tampoco me refiero al
territorio inmediato voy a dar otro
otro ejemplo y es seguramente que por
ejemplo en el tema de la salud que es
otro de los temas que también nos
devanan los sesos
digamos a los que trabajamos en estos
temas evidentemente hay cosas que hay
que acercar y otras que pueden estar muy
lejos
hace poco nos preguntábamos por ejemplo
cómo lográbamos que la población
migrante pudiera acceder a la salud
entonces nos inventamos que lo mejor en
lugar de buscar todas las rutas para que
la población pudiera ir a todos los
centros de salud nos inventamos que
nadie en la salud se acercara a ellos y
nos inventamos una unidad móvil y en esa
unidad móvil no solamente la pensamos
como una ambulancia que transporta gente
a los hospitales sino que además
pudieran ahí mismo brindar atención
médica inmediatamente de lo nuevo pero
antes ahora vamos a tener que montarle
casi una universidad para poder que para
que pudiera tener todos los médicos y
todos los especialistas que necesitaba
la unidad móvil y mi respuesta fue no
ahí es donde se sirve en internet es
decir todas las muestras que tomemos
aquí las podemos mandar si queremos en
su lugar más lejano en europa o en
cualquier país que tenga la especialidad
para hacer una lectura de los resultados
que quiero decir no hay una respuesta
seguramente hay una múltiple una
múltiple realidad de respuestas pero la
pregunta sigue siendo la misma como
acercamos la demanda a la oferta en esta
pregunta que parece después digamos
obvia pero que va al bien lo que hacemos
es tener respuestas obvias y preguntando
la profundidad pueden surgir increíbles
e invenciones sobre las situaciones más
críticas hay países por ejemplo que
frente a los temas más profundos de
analfabetismo lo que hizo fue sacar a
los maestros sacar a los niños a los
territorios llevarlos a donde estaban la
gente sembrando trabajando a las
fábricas para hacer alfabetización
entonces precisamente superar esa
barrera de que la única forma a
alfabetizar era llevar a todo el mundo a
la escuela y no sacar a los maestros a
los otros digamos al campo a donde
estaban las necesidades fue una
respuesta aunque la pregunta es una
pregunta que lleva precisamente en estos
momentos de crisis a ser grandes
reinvenciones todos nos estamos
reinventando el señor que está el señor
de rap y que nos pruebe la comida en la
señora que tiene que ver cómo educar a
los niños pero no tiene el maestro lo
que si no quisiera es que cayéramos como
en el facilismo de pensar eso quiere
decir que ahora entramos al mundo del
internet no porque muchos de los
servicios no son posibles de tener por
internet la energía el agua y la
atención médica una operación eso no
quiere decir que esa es la única
respuesta quiere decir que esa es una de
las respuestas necesarias para poder que
solucionar esta gran distancia que
tenemos entre las necesidades y las
respuestas a nuestras necesidades tal
vez en este mundo esté pregunté cómo
acercar
las demandas y las ofertas son las más
interesantes que me he encontrado fue
acerca del tema de la alimentación una
propuesta que se desarrolló en europa
sobre slow food es como poder acercar el
alimento a las poblaciones y una de las
cosas que decía base interesante es que
no entendían por qué se traían las
galletas de eeuu o europa a sitios donde
estaban todos los ingredientes que en
lugar de estar tallando las galletas lo
mejor era traer la receta y en ser en
efecto traer la receta hubiera sido la
posibilidad y en lugar de estar
transportando alimentos por todas partes
del mundo ya poder aprovechar los
recursos que están inmediatos en el
entorno para poder tener el alimento que
estábamos buscando y así hicieron una
propuesta muy interesante que se llama
'kilómetro cero' precisamente que es
cómo aprovechar los alimentos que están
en el entorno y transportarlos lo menos
posible entonces hay cosas que vamos a
tener que transportar y hay cosas que no
vamos a tener que transportar lo
importante es la pregunta y esta
pregunta es fundamental para que no nos
ocurra la parada
de que ahora este lugar de aplaudir
porque tenemos el 90 por ciento de los
niños que van a la escuela para educarse
es el 90 por ciento de los niños que
tienen que ir a la escuela para poderse
educar no tienen educación en estas
circunstancias aunque tenemos el 90% del
cubrimiento de agua entubada en momentos
de crisis o cuando no hay agua potable
ese 90% baja al 60% porque el agua no es
potable
todas estas son las preguntas que
queremos hacer quisiera cerrar con una
reflexión hace unos días en esta época
del rebusque que estamos viendo también
en las calles un uno de los señores que
venden me vendió este carro y entonces
qué quieres que de ella salió usted de
hacer estos carros mejor si yo hago
estos carros porque
porque le ayudaba a recibir un ingreso y
venir porque así carlos porque no hace
otras cosas que hace pajaritos o porque
lo hace otro tipo de cosas dice porque
es lo que yo siempre han querido tener
es un carro porque el carro me permite
me permitiría llevar a mis hijos a la
escuela me permitiría llevar y llevar a
mi esposa cuando va a dar a luz hasta el
hospital porque el carro es el que me
permite tener el mercado en mi casa
porque el carro porque el carro este era
su sueño tener un instrumento de
movilidad que le permitiera acceder a
los servicios y a la oferta que pueden
resolver sus necesidades hoy
paradójicamente esa no puede ser la
única solución y esta no es la solución
a todas las necesidades si logramos que
el tema es que la educación la puedan
recibir los niños en su misma casa o en
su misma comunidad o puedan ir caminando
que la salud sea móvil que muchos de los
servicios se acerquen a ellos pues de
pronto éste no va a ser el único sueño
que tenga él porque su verdadero sueño
más que tener carro está en el agua está
en la educación que están en energía
y suscribir sus necesidades bueno esta
era mi está en la forma de compartir
sobre todo una pregunta que creo que
ahora compartimos muchos y que espero
que este reencuentro no seamos habla
nuestro para encuentro entre las
personas sino que sea un recuerdo entre
la educación y los niños la salud y
quienes los necesitan y todos los demás
bienes del desarrollo
i
a
ah